la parole est maintenant notre collègue
d'yvette lopez pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
les élections qui viennent de se
dérouler ont été une nouvelle occasion
de constater une grande désespérance de
la population des territoires oubliés de
la république pendant cette campagne
nous avons entendu le cri d'une france
qui se sent exclue de votre politique
votre gouvernement méprisent ouvertement
la ruralité que vous savez que vous
semblez avoir relégué comme une
catégorie sociologique appartenant au
passé
pour la gauche la ruralité c'est un mode
appelé à disparaître tout disparaît les
transports les services publics l'emploi
les écoles les médecins les commerces de
proximité tous ceux qui composent le
tissu social de cette phrase des
territoires auxquels le compatriote de
la plupart sont issus sont viscéralement
attachés depuis des années le
gouvernement déversent des sommes
considérables dans les bas lieu à se
détourner d'une ruralité qui échappe à
l'idéologie qui vous habite d'une france
qui ne serait fait que les grandes
métropoles de grandes régions dans
lesquelles nos compatriotes ne se
retrouvent plus dernièrement il a fallu
que le sénat répondent à votre
indifférence avec une proposition de loi
proposant des mesures structurelles sur
l'agriculture comme vous nous voulons
examiner
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
enfin prendre conscience qu'il est
urgent de renouer avec une politique
intelligente d'aménagement du territoire
que vous semblez avoir retiré de votre
paysage mental
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame sylvia pinel ministre du logement
de l'égalité des territoires la ruralité
pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
nous connaissons les craintes les
inquiétudes des habitants des
territoires ruraux et périurbains et
nous n'avons pas attendu avec le premier
ministre votre question pour s'en
préoccuper je pourrais ici vous rappeler
votre bilan en la matière et le
délaissement de ces territoires sous le
quinquennat précédent à l'occasion des
deux comités interministériels ruralité
nous avons proposé plus de 60 cette
mesure extrêmement concrètes qui
répondent précisément aux préoccupations
que vous avez exprimé en ce qui concerne
les services publics
avec l'accélération des des maisons de
services de 8000 d'ici la fin de l'année
2016 en installant des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires dans les territoires
déficitaire en luttant contre les
déserts médicaux en soutenant la
création de postes d'enseignants dans
ces territoires là alors que vous en
aviez supprimé de nombreux en permettant
aussi le développement économique et
l'aménagement du territoire avec le plan
france très haut débit et je pourrais
continuer longtemps à citer ces mesures
donc madame la sénatrice vous le voyez
le gouvernement a une vision globale et
transversale de l'aménagement de ces
territoires et à la différence de votre
question nous n'opposons pas les
territoires urbains les banlieues la
politique de la ville parce que nous
avons besoin de tous ces territoires
pour construire une république forte
merci à toi collègues vive est obèse
pour la réplique à la ministre il n'y a
pas d'amour il y a que des preuves
d'amour et vous le savez bien
votre gouvernement à abandonner les
pôles d'excellence ruraux plutôt que de
parler de ya trois ans et demi j'aurai
pu souhaiter que vous vous tourniez vers
l'avenir
votre gouvernement à abandonner l'époque
d'excellence ruraux votre gouvernement à
diminuer les crédits du fonds fisac pour
le commerce
ils atteignent le montant dérisoire de
10 millions d'euros pour toute la france
vous avez totalement vidés de leur
propre tiko conclure allait diminuer de
moitié derrère ya trop copieux où je
joue bien ça vaut plus que nous pour que
la ruralité tu la question pour en
conclure oublié